Trên đại hội đại biểu văn của lần thứ 14 của đàn cộng sản Việt Nam,
cai mạng hay mùi thăm một nhiều hãng chuyển thông của tế đang tài các phần tích cho rằng
Việt Nam đang đứng trước thời cơ quan trọng để bất phá về kinh tế giá hội.
Bảo nếu các trời em s nhân định, nếu miếp bốn có ý nghĩa lần nhất trong nhiều thịp niên,
khi Việt Nam là những kinh tế nặng lộng cao hàng đầu cho á đối mắt với câu hội tôn nhất,
thậm chí là câu hội quý c控 để rộ lên trước khi giá hóa,
nông thời cần theo đối cật cả các tạo bạo vườn sau của 15 mấy,
trang một đơn tiếp lộ mề xí cho rằng rửa thảo nghiệp của Việt Nam là hội mì bốn thế,
hệ yêu tiền giòn nét cho anh linh và tăng trực bị tế,
với một tiêu tăng trưởng bình quan, ý nhất, mười phần trăm mối năm trong năm tử ý,
thật hình giả này xưa một định chính trị tiếp tục là yếu tổ tạo niềm tiên cho nhà đồ tư của tế,
tại Trung Quốc quan sát tưởng hại và một sảo vá trường góm,
nhìn mạnh các một tiêu phát triển giải hạn đến năm 2020 và 2020,
cùng bà đồ phá trên lượng về tế chế,
một tụi bà hạt tân dựa trên hàng trị ổ y kênh ở góc của người dân trong khi đó bà đồ bà đồ mướng nhận định,
ở Mỹ bốn sẽ cùng cố định bớm kinh tế ví mô,
thuộc lời của bực tư nhăn lần cao chủ ra trị và tăng tháng trống trịu của người kinh tế,
trước các tụi sốc bên ngoài.